hey guys sorry that it's been a little
bit longer than I usually like to do
since the last time I put up a video you
might have guessed up from my voice I
have been sick so despite having seen
Moana having seen arrival i have not had
the energy to do a review editor review
whatever but um what I am gonna do is
something that I have not done in quite
a while and that is a reaction video yay
and then of course in this case it's
going to be to the spider-man homecoming
trailer which was released last night
which is when most people got their
reaction videos out so even trying to do
something like this I can't quite do it
right but there's there were two that
will release the US the international
i'm not going to do library actions both
because i'm expecting it the differences
to be pretty minor they usually are so
i'm going to do a reaction to the US one
which is the one that actually aired on
i guess it was Jimmy Kimmel I don't know
how to watch that kind of stuff but it
doubt quit rambling and let's fire this
thing up okay
[Music]
we're doing the cut everything sup guys
you guys on the real Avengers I can tell
hope gives it away that's a fun start I
love his energy it's just terrific no
you seen that before it's a really
annoying sound probably starts
downpouring it's creepy up silly guys
are losers tific coming Avengers oh
they're like trials or any movie just
don't do anything i would do and
definitely don't do anything I wouldn't
do there's a little gray area in there
and that's what you want for me yeah
alright that's good advice from Tony
Stark's where I'm the top right okay
good luck out there how do you go Jack
still with us oh yeah yeah I know you
want to save the world but who took
footage of the airport fight here's the
spider-man no no this is just posturing
it's true seeing close to the boy
and stay in trouble
sorry I'm not saying more is it whoo
forget the flying monster guy there are
people who handle the stress that's a
cool look on the ball trick I like that
lower a kid this is my chance to prove
myself sorry i'm so busy i'm sad
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
a wall okay aha
[Music]
all right okay um that was pretty good
um you probably saw I was smiling
through most of that and you know I
don't talk too much while it's going on
cuz trying to watch the thing but for
the most part that was good i like i
still i love tom holland in this part
he's great i love his energy and he is
he is he is really a terrific happy
marriage between what Tobey Maguire was
good at and what Andrew Garfield was
good I cuz Tobey Maguire was really good
at sort of the dorky loserish aspect of
Peter Parker and andrew garfield was
really good in the suit you know
swinging around y'all having a having a
bit of fun and and being a little more
slick with it and Tom Hollands of a
really good marriage of those two
aspects so I'm liking him a lot nothing
no nothing to complain about in him um
Tony Stark while his bits in here seemed
like they made sense and seemed organic
they also felt slightly shoehorned in
I'm a little bit when I saw him actually
flying in the Iron Man suit honestly
that makes me slightly oh is that
necessary I don't make me want to see
the movie it will be but from a trailer
reaction like it's spider-man you don't
need to throw I I mean have Tony Stark
fine they've established their
relationship you don't need to throw the
actual Iron Man suit in there too I do
like what Tony Stark said you know in
terms of that you know you're not ready
to save the world keep it small and i
think that's that's a good approach and
i think even though despite mine is
obviously going against the vulture who
Tony tells them not to the movie is
actually following that advice it is
keeping it small because it's keeping it
you know to a to a single guy I
seriously doubt the vulture has a world
dominating scheme so it's they're not
making the mistake that say the first
amazing spider-man made the where you
know the lizards got to infect the whole
city is like what the gate that that's a
little much like right off the bat so it
looks like that they're keeping it on a
title more intimate level of like that I
love the look of the vulture and I like
the couple lines we got from Michael
Keaton that was really good um uh trying
to think what okay the the sort of thing
at the end where I was like whoa um was
that he's trying to hold the ship
together with his webbing which it was a
very cool image but I had two things
happen in my
back-to-back first was like wow that's
cool second was like they are really
going out of their way to try and one-up
the the train sequence from spider-man 2
and and I mean in terms of a single
image it kind of does I have to wonder
if in terms of the sequence as it goes
along if it's going to feel too much
like a retread of the train scene in
spider-man 2 which I think feasibly
could be a problem because that's one of
the best most memorable parts of that
with him stopping that train with his
webbing and his body just sheer you see
the stress of it on a man I'm just
worried about that being a slightly
slightly recycled thing but I'm not
gonna lie in the moment when I first saw
that image it reaction was whoa so I'm
you know looks good it's impactful
certainly um what I am most excited to
see in this it is Tom Holland in the
part um I'm my little excitement for the
film overall is it's there it's not it's
not stratospheric because even though
marble is largely taking over this is
still a sony product and sony at this
point the well I I i don't know if i can
say i have less faith in them that even
I have DC but it's probably comparable
they haven't done it right in a while so
but I love this kit I love this kid is
spider-man I think he is awesome and if
you're going to do the younger
spider-man which initially I didn't want
them to I kind of wanted them to do the
adult spider-man the guy in his 30s the
guy who was passed the teen drama aspect
of spider-man because even though a lot
of fans latch onto that go oh but that's
what it's about that was what it was
about in the 60s and early 70s but then
he graduated college and he had he had a
life so we don't have to keep going back
to high school over and over again and
even though I still kind of think that
if you're going to do high school
spider-man this kid nails that
absolutely without question so that was
good um so I guess I'll wrap this up
there I'll take a look at the
international trial like I said I'm not
going to do a live reaction to that as
well because i can't imagine it'll be
that different watch I'll watch it'll be
like fifty percent in from footage and
I'll go why didn't I do it but I who
knows um so that's gonna be it for me
folks um thanks so much for tuning in
again I I'm
largely over the as bad as I sound I'm
largely over this cold so hopefully
updates will be a little bit more
regular from here on out please you know
the usual spiel like subscribe check out
the council geek podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher you can follow me on
twitter at council of geeks i'm also on
facebook council geeks all that so sue
me social media stuff I can speak so
yeah so until next time folks this
council is adjourned